my back and knee pain have greatly
improved by ignoring infomercials
[Music]
in this installment of the yes or no
game we are joined by a giant a giant of
politics and a giant of person it's a
very tall man that would be my friend
Charlie Kirk I'm not the Nephilim you
are not you are not you've never proven
to me that you're not but I am giving
you the best there is a Reddit thread
that says is Charlie part of the
Nephilim
how did what did they conclude it's
uncertain it's uncertain
if you want to ponder important
questions such as is Charlie among the
Nephilim you've got to get the yes or no
game right now you go to dailywire.com
shop we sold out once I told you we were
going to sell out then we ordered many
thousands more copies and what have I
told you you got to pre-order we're
gonna sell out we sold out again we have
ordered thousands and thousands of
copies pre-order it daily wire.com shop
play for yourself now we are going to
play Charlie okay you much more
responsible man than I you have a cup of
coffee here I do I have a martini maybe
I spiked your coffee who knows who knows
we'll find out that would be cruel but
just even at the playing field you know
with the game have you seen the rules at
all somewhat yeah okay so like a
drinking game I will go first
short men are worse at politics okay I
am at least three quarters of an inch
larger than the average in the United
States Ben Davies
so short men or how do I think you're
gonna answer yes and I'll answer how
okay well so I'm answering on behalf of
you
you're right
for your position yes okay
oh 100 but it's not it's not an exact
rule there's some awful tall politicians
there were some awful to I now like Bill
de Blasio is awful and he is very tall
he's incredibly tall so the reason I see
that answer is Presidents the taller
candidate generally wins
my reason for no though is that you've
met many United States senators you're
friends with some of them as am I
they're not the tallest Bunch the U.S
senators that I know not presidents but
senators and especially members of
Congress
some of them are like five six you know
these are some fairly diminutive people
I don't know why there's a difference
between presidents and legislators but
that's just what I've noticed so by a
numbers game
I think these guys are pretty good so I
think the question was do politicians
have a Napoleonic complex no short men
are worse at politics or Worse they're
not as good at it but that but aren't
you agreeing the Senate's awful
we know but they're good at politics
okay I'm sorry okay I understand
on their politics okay got it so wow so
well the taller candidate does usually
win yeah for president I mean I'm going
to get so much hate for this I generally
don't trust short people in power
what about generally it's a general rule
what would be a good example but short
is very subjective what about uh
DeSantis he's not a very tall he's like
five eleven-ish right five six foot
everyone
I think it's more like I'm six three six
fours I don't want to get called out by
the DeSantis campaign I think it's more
like five
nine or ten he's not a very tall guy as
far as I can tell but he's a good good
governor
what about I'm trying to think of
another good Rand Paul I like Rand Paul
Rand Paul's great it's not very tall not
very tall what about um but there's also
some I mean you could be too tall in
politics like George Pataki Way Too Tall
he was way too tall he was and I mean
Glenn youngin Way Too Tall I've never
met James Comey Way Too Tall you're like
it's true you are not from this Earth
yeah and I would definitely agree with
that as well okay so I'm gonna just
drink okay even though we both got that
right are you just looking for an excuse
yes Charlie when I did lahayam chin chin
we played this game
that's well made we played this game
during during Lent this is the first
time I ever gave up booze like in my
life and we were catholic that's tough
it's very tough I mean we are sort of
born into a part of the ceremony I mean
we uh I gave it up I've got to make up
for lost time okay you're right all
right
the Boy Scouts are now just Retreats for
Libs
yeah I'm an eagle scout so that's I went
to the Boy Scouts you're you're right
that's sad isn't that sad you're an
eagle scout that's supposed to be a very
impressive prestigious thing yes and now
these days
they took out the word boy didn't they
no yeah they allow girls in the Boy
Scouts that's bad
a drink did I guess correctly you did
okay I just chose
it was a long it was a long length I'm
up
women are funny
so you okay
[Music]
like obviously the exceptions exist
exceptions
yeah yeah that's true
Christopher Hitchens said there were
three exceptions to that rule
I don't know if I can say them even he
published it in Vanity Fair so I feel he
said that the only exceptions to women
not being funny these are his words
they're not mine I don't want he said
they have to be Hefty Dyke or Jewish
or Canadian and I don't he didn't maybe
you could add that as an addendum isn't
there a strange amount of comedians that
come from Canada that's true but I bet
for women they still fall into one of
those three because all of the when you
think of the really prominent female
comedians
almost all of them fall into one of
those three groups
we could have an hours-long discussion
of why that is
it my turn you're up
my back and knee pain have greatly
improved by ignoring infomercials
By ignoring information I would say you
would say no
I think you would say yes I think I know
your pain reduction medium of choice
that's true and it has nothing to do
with infomercial it has nothing to do
with 100 drug free
um
did I guess correctly
no yeah yeah you have
that's great it's 100 drug free relief
Factor though it is true and you throw a
football great now thank you yes
perfectly that commercial went viral
it's good it did it was an excellent
commercial well I think people were very
confused because they're so used to like
the catheter commercial or the gold
reverse mortgage pillow
I will admit I or Larry Elder on a boat
yes when I first saw the commercial
Charlie I thought look I like I like
relief factor a lot of my friends
endorse relay factor I love Charlie I
said but usually the people in these
commercials are like 110 years old and
Charlie's like 20. so I do have an awful
back that is that is an actual thing I
know I remember I I think I may have
texted you about it no it's it's been a
real
challenge for years yeah I want to get a
good commercial like I've never been all
the little clips that come up that you
know the libs make fun of I've never had
a great commercial like that I don't
think Bud Light will call anytime an
Target as special special influencer
give me that can I could look great on
there right now head on over to
expressvpn.com Michael YT think for a
moment about the idea that a single
company controls ninety nine zero
percent of internet searches runs your
email service and gets to track
everything you do on your smartphone big
Tech is more powerful than most
countries and it profits by exploiting
your personal data it is time to put a
layer of protection between your online
activity and these Tech Juggernauts and
that is why I strongly recommend
expressvpn this is the only VPN that I
use it's super easy I'm a huge Luddite
you just download it click one button
boom you're online very very simple
think about how much of your life is on
the internet every site you visit every
video you watch every message you send
gets tracked data or mind when you use
expressvpn on your devices the software
hides your IP address something big Tech
can use to personally identify you
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your internet
data to keep you safe from hackers and
Eaves droppers on your network if I can
do it you can do it too very very simple
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button you're protected
expressvpn does all of that without
slowing down your connection so stop
handing over your personal data go to
expressvpn.com Michael YT get three
extra months for free that is
expresvpn.com Michael YT expressvpn.com
Michael YT to learn more you're up no
I'm no Europe okay
we really gave McCarthyism a bad rap
my only hold up is who's we or which
McCarthy and wish McCarthy Dan McCarthy
at isi we gave that guy a bad rep uh to
quote William F Buckley Jr
to paraphrase him because I don't have
it Word Perfect McCarthyism
is a political movement around which all
Americans of stern moral fiber can rally
yeah he was right I wish the house
committed on American activities would
have done more yeah and they were right
they were right they were Senator
Hollywood they were Communists and
culture he got Alger Hiss he was he was
one of the top dogs like founded the U.N
the Intel agency's turned McCarthyism
into a slur
yeah you're right of course of course
Joe McCarthy uh he burned too bright for
our age
good man from Wisconsin okay
at this point 95 of all white
supremacists are actually undercover
feds
[Music]
this is too predictable the other five
percent are Indian Or Hispanic
I've discovered
I also love that our answers are just
exact no they're just almost every time
except for the tall guy one the tall guy
one we'll get back to that one later
there's a lot there there's a lot
there's a lot we could Plumb the depths
of that
similar to people who drink Bud Light
people who don't drink at all always
seem to be hiding something from their
father
oh
we seem to be hiding something from
their father similar to people who drink
Bud Light that's people who don't drink
okay
I know yeah I don't know if you believe
that I don't believe it yeah because
especially some people I know don't
drink for religious reasons or from
they've never had a drink before
a number of the people I know who don't
drink don't drink because they've
really had maybe one or two too many at
times and they've really lived life and
they might be hiding all sorts of things
but they're not hiding the kind of
things that people who drink Bud Light
all right in my experience
all right next one yep okay
okay
recycling it's both fake and gay
our producer slips in a fake and gay
question every time every single episode
recycling is both fake and gay
yeah I can't imagine you're kind of like
a zealot for recycling no when we moved
into I guess our house maybe it's an
apartment it was our house
my wife she goes to me she goes Meg said
yeah girl she goes can we now like we're
in our own place can we not recycle and
I said you know it and you know it this
is our home we can do whatever we want
it is also we'll put the gay thing aside
for a second it is fake it doesn't
recycling isn't real so much of what we
put into the recycling bin just ends up
in some trash Heap in China or more
likely in the middle of the ocean it's
not a thing it's like it's like a barely
a thing right but basically yeah
oh
producing and distributing pornographic
only fans content should be banned and
have criminal consequences
[Music]
for minors or just in general in general
producing and distributing pornographic
only fancy it's very this is a very
specific incredible even genre of
pornography yeah so like not the other
pornography just this type yeah I guess
or at least this type
is that so producing and distributing
yeah
the production and distribution the
distribution is a key here it's a very
very legally specific question okay
um
foreign
yeah I mean I think you're kind of like
the integral I strike so here you go I
yeah I mean you know there's never been
a separation of church and state ever in
my opinion
um
it's a hard one because you would go
after like 200 other kinds of
pornography first before you got to but
I mean porn is a cancer on society but
it's a cancer if you're telling me at
least we'll ban this I'd say yeah of
course it's not it's it's released like
age verification and like also I mean
that's like a base Baseline but it's
it's it's so awful only fans is
particularly Insidious actually because
any young girl who's 18 and wants to
make a quick buck and 18 year olds are
not known for making the wisest
decisions can log on to this thing snap
some pictures she'll almost certainly
not make any money anyway this is how
fast Ian Bargains often work and then
those pictures will be there forever
it's going to it's going to it's not
going to necessarily ruin her life but
it's going to complicate her life a lot
and you know she could be out of it two
months later but the damage is already
done you think that's just awful I mean
it's just it's just degenerate men
preying on vulnerable gullible women and
desperate women for what to arouse the
lusts of other men there's just
everyone's a victim in the whole I mean
everyone is degraded it doesn't Point
towards virtue at all no so did I get
that right yeah yeah yeah I mean it
wouldn't be my top like right I'd go
after the like ones a regime of what we
want to go after but I I think that I
mean look pornography is made is it's a
it's an it's a tumor on society yeah it
is I I I've often thought when people
talk about why is everything getting so
crazy and irrational and degraded and I
think well so there's this thing that
not a lot of people want to talk about
which which what 90 plus 95 plus percent
of men have looked at at some point and
maybe oh no I I had my struggles with it
and I talk about it and I'm I try to
warn young men not to not to look yeah
no I I wish it would have been harder
for me to access it because think about
the the median age of exposure to porn
is like 11. it's unbelievable and for
some people obviously it's much younger
so if you if you've got a society that
is like imagine if you had 90 of society
hooked on
opium and but no one talked about it and
it was totally legal and easy to obtain
you get opium delivered to your phone
unless little portal to hell like any
time you wanted that would probably mess
up our politics wouldn't it so if you've
got opium but it but instead of just
damaging your the rest of your body it
melts your brain it makes you view human
beings as nothing but like sacks of
Flesh to be used that
is probably going to have a political
effect well it's even worse than that
because you have a built-in as men
especially desire to procreate yeah and
it completely destroys the ability to do
that in a way that is virtuous in a way
that is ethical in a way that is moral
in a way that is grounded in a way that
is traditional yeah yeah I mean it I
believe most of the depression of young
men can be from dopamine deprivation of
pornographic addiction oh that's
interesting that it's not even just a
depression of this is a degrading
shameful act but it's like actually no I
think it's actually I mean there's a
fabulous book Gary Wilson's book your
brain on porn yeah yeah I haven't read
it no I mean it's it's he actually just
passed away it's too bad because he was
such an articulate Defender he doesn't
even religious guy he's like this is
causing issues across the board of male
self-confidence male suicide male
depression male anxiety and female as
well but I mean what's really sad is
female pornography habits are actually
increasing right now really yeah they
are and so I mean yeah the spirit of the
question is I mean are laws should make
it harder to do the things we know that
do not have any sort of Redemptive value
yes yeah and edifying value I mean these
these laws actually do exist we did jail
pornographers until very recently the
bush administer Bush number two jailed a
pornographer for obscenity at the end of
his well and this is where I mean you
wrote a whole book on it where this is
not this is not what the founding
fathers had in mind for speech no this
this would have been labeled
licentiousness right it would have been
profane not holy right it would have
been outlandish and against actually how
human beings should live this is
clarifying yeah yeah screw only fans we
got it yeah that's we I should have
answered even more quickly than I
already did uh am I up okay
this is not that controversial uh fine
I'll say it teachers are overpaid
I actually
oh really I know I mean look in certain
but New York California there's yeah
we're I'm very biased where I grew up
the union bosses are overpaid well they
actually do a great job for their
members they're just what they do is
corrupt the institution for the students
but in certain places the teachers are
overpaid but in a lot of the rest of
America teachers are severely underpaid
which creates a difficult incentive
problems where they become much more
reliant on the union so they got to
follow what the union sets for them so
they can't provide a good education it
it's like all of these leftist politics
you know a couple of these like Piggies
at the top get get all the riches and
then a lot of other hotels are deprived
yeah exactly yeah I mean I grew up in
district 214 in Chicago where gym
teachers make 127 000 a year right and
they you guys can factor I could go to
openthebooks.com Adam and gieski's
website you'll see the average wages in
district 214 in the suburbs of Chicago
for Math teachers gym teachers upwards
175 000 a year for yeah no this is you
guys could fact check it it's all right
think about that annualized because you
get the summer off first of all then you
get 80 of that as a pension obligation
once they
once they retire right so to answer I
mean you got this right in my experience
but yes there are some places Across
America where teachers are woefully
underpaid yeah but the solution is fire
Bad Teachers we have way too many
teachers yeah and way too many
administrators right that's the real
killer though yeah that's true okay
excluding speaking out against the
Catholic Church
the death penalty is wrong
well I don't even get the parenthetical
excluding speaking out against the
Catholic church I think that's more
directed towards you like I like I don't
need to feel like I'm speaking up no I
think it meant that you would execute
people that would speak out against the
church oh okay I wrote that question it
was written for you yeah you make a
great point Thank you for interpreting
what it's the vodka but yeah it is Jen
thank you very much I'm not drinking
teenage white girl oh yeah
I I find for a martini it's got to be oh
orwellian of you it's well no the the
Vodka thing gin is the drink of choice
in 1984. it oh that's right wow though I
hope this is better than the Big Brother
Jen who knows though daily wire budgets
are kind of you know slipping a little
bit okay so the death penalty is wrong
I know where you stand on this death
penalty is wrong no so it's very this is
a really interesting one I um
this is my most unclear political
position hmm I I used to be very against
the death penalty very much for multiple
reasons I used to somewhat morally but
that that's actually not a good argument
executing the wrong person really
bothers me and that does happen and that
there's there's a finality to the
punishment right
and well is there well if they're not
saved yeah right I mean there's that old
line from Dr Johnson which is uh depend
upon it sir when a man's to be hanged in
a fortnight it concentrates his mind
wonderfully so you kind of hope there is
if you are facing execution it almost
accelerates the the confrontation of yes
who am I where am I going who's my God
so if we look at it strictly biblically
there is no argument to say the the it
is the Bible is 100 supportive of the
death penalty yeah it is without
question and I think in Catholic
teaching they're so screwed up when well
they're against the death penalty yeah
the the TR the teaching of the church
for
um just about 2000 years is quite clear
that the death penalty is A-Okay doctors
of the church in fact it's necessary
that was the old teaching of the church
I mean there there's there were many
popes who've carried it out including uh
Pope who was beatified on his way to
sainthood uh uh blessed Pious the ninth
who he was the last Pope in the Papal
States before they got rid of the Papal
States he was asked for a stay of
execution by the last criminal to be
executed and his answer was we cannot do
it and we do not want to so the church
was very unless you're telling me that
Saint Paul you know advocated something
deeply immoral or intrinsically evil
that's all obviously no but I mean the
Old Testament law in particular was very
clear about life for a life yeah right
about what actually gets the death
penalty yeah which is even if an animal
act an ox accidentally kills a human
being Exodus 20 or 21 you must kill the
ox you do not keep it yeah yeah and you
know the there are some Modern Catholics
who have tried to make this argument
again and I guess Protestants too
we've tried to make this argument that
the death penalty undermines human
dignity but right back there in Genesis
the the explanation for the death
penalty is actually to defend Humanity
no that's correct right yes it's life
for life is what it is and it's in fact
for example I mean the first recorded
murder ever in Genesis 3 yeah of Genesis
4 Cain and Abel where
um Cain kills Abel you remember God said
it you didn't just kill Abel you kill
it's the ground that is shrieking
meaning
it's the future Generations who killed
of him think about that so it's not just
him it is what he would have done it is
the people he would have influenced the
sons or daughters he would have had but
with that being said yeah what was the
what was the exact wording of the
question death penalty's wrong the death
penalty is wrong that's a moral question
so you did answer correctly that I'd say
it's political but I would say in
America I would oppose the death penalty
for a very specific reason because right
now the trend is this current government
will use any power we give them against
us that so I am and this is the Patriot
Act argument right the moral argument
I'm totally on board we had a government
that was ethical and understood you know
Duty and you're saying just you think
the government's so far gone that
they're they could in the practically
right now in America I think we should
oppose the death penalty we shouldn't
because they could start executing
Charlie they would
like it's pretty bad but I'm just saying
you don't know it's that bad they're not
but they're not they're not doing it yet
at least the death penalty part yeah
they barely carry out the death penalty
no because right now opposing the death
penalty fits their agenda which is to
try to have compassion supersede Justice
right but make make no mistake as soon
as the actual Bolsheviks take over
they're going to want to bring back the
geek yeah right you're going to come to
this table the idea that Michael Knowles
and Charlie could still be in a gulag on
Alba is like no no no we gotta wipe them
off he's still a threat he's still
breathing yeah right we don't get the
vacation to Alba that's probably true
that's probably true I'll drink to that
anyway to our
you know impending doom no one here Gets
Out Alive anyway we'll go to heaven
cheers yeah I certainly hope so
in Catholic Church are you guys certain
of your have have an assurances well if
we don't uh if we don't reject God's
grace and if we don't uh you know die in
a state of mortal sin if we if we die in
the State of Grace
um which is available to us by you know
cooperating with God's grace and
accepting Christ and being contrived for
our sins and all the rest of that then
we can go to heaven might need a little
expurgation period but you know uh but
but but there is a risk even you know
I'm baptized got the sacraments
confirmed in the faith but if I reject
God and I choose with the ascent of my
will to
commit mortal sins
I could be liable to the fire there
there is biblical evidence for this that
Protestants have to wrestle with there
is unforgivable sin in the Ten
Commandments yep and of course Jesus
alludes to the you know I never knew who
you were yeah and and Christ says the uh
you know there's the unforgivable sin of
blasphemy in the Holy Spirit oh that's
exactly which which is uh which is sort
of what I'm describing here which is you
know that you you do still have that
Free Will well so blasphemy the holy
spirit is the same essence of what is
the one unforgivable sin of the Ten
Commandments
you know do not carry the lord's name in
vain hmm
it's the same thing that's interesting
do not blasphemy the Holy Spirit do not
carry the lord's name in advance
hmm but one could blasphemy it's not the
same thing but it's in essence yeah yeah
there's there's a which is which is a
rejection or a misuse of of the name of
God or the language of God or the
rejection thereof
I have to I'll have to meditate on that
because I was trying I was going through
this recently because I figured if I
make some stray comment if I laugh at a
joke where someone mentions the Holy
Spirit could I have committed the
unforgivable sin and it's not it's not
quite that right I mean and so no but I
think the essence of Christ's teaching
is did you reject the advocate right did
you reject what I left you yeah yeah
right yeah I am so as Christ descended
to the Holy Spirit came down in
Pentecost which is here for us to be
able to do his his gifts right the the
fruits of the spirit yeah love joy peace
patience kindness goodness gentleness
and self-control are the fruits of the
spirit but then also the gifts of the
Spirit right healing speaking of tongues
Etc yeah yeah that's I think Europe okay
you can go again yeah
if I had to choose between the two most
the two corrupt world leaders named
Vladimir
I would have I would have more fun
playing yes or no with Putin oh I see
what you're saying who would you have
more fun playing yesterday or Putin yes
yeah okay right um and so it's saying I
would have more fun with Putin
that's the prompt yeah correct yeah okay
no doubt right yeah not that uppity Ford
or in a T-shirt
that is the most beautiful description
I've heard of the leader of Ukraine yeah
I didn't come up with as Tuckers but it
was Tucker ah Tucker he's got something
it says in the Bible that you will you
must honor those who you have things
from I just have I have a good memory
you know it's funny success leaves Clues
you know what's funny about Putin
until very recently he was
if not idolized he was exalted by the
West he was a world economic Forum a
young Global leader he was because they
thought they could liberalize Russia
they thought they could liberalize
Russia see Putin's not a good guy he's a
thug okay but this idea that somehow we
in the west don't do deals with thugs is
just one of the most laughable
geopolitical arguments I've ever heard
the whole Russia thing is one of the
great cons pulled on the American people
right now the fact that we're giving a
dollar to this failed project of the
current state of Ukraine first of all
zelenski's a really bad person he is
corrupt he's a liar he's a cheat Ukraine
is not known for its sex first of all
it's a fake country
the way it's currently constituted there
is a Ukrainian people eastern Ukraine is
part of Russia they speak Russian they
want to be part of Russia Crimea you
heard of the Yalta Conference that's in
Crimea right right literally
yeah I mean so why is this our problem
is the more important question right
Ukraine has been conquered so many times
by so many people it was even conquered
by the polls Poland is one of the most
conquered places on Earth itself and yet
Poland conquered let me be clear Putin
invading Ukraine's a bad thing yeah
we're not us exasperating the conflict
and not trying to broker piece is also a
bad thing you know going back to the
early 90s you had serious American
Statesmen including conservatives who
said hey NATO as a defensive Alliance
probably shouldn't expand too much
Eastward Dennis you have lady Graham
going right up to the border of Ukraine
saying we're going to play offense this
is the year we're going to go back to DC
could you imagine if the Russians of the
Chinese went to Mexico City yeah in fact
we know what that is we know what
happens when it's called the Cuban
Missile Crisis yeah it was probably a
bad look for the director of the CIA to
arrive in Kiev two weeks after the
maidan revolution that may have had a
little bit of support from the totally
Democratic
Grassroots not the best look and but yet
all these Sam Nunn Kissinger Dan Patrick
Moynihan all these guys George Kennan
author of The Long Telegram saying hey
NATO if you keep expanding Eastward in
antagonize Russia that's going to
escalate the prospects for war if you
don't respect buffer states which have
played an important role historically
that's going to increase the risks of
war and then
what do we get and then Biden literally
invited the guy to invade people
underestimate how much of how big of a
role social issues play in the Ukrainian
conflict is that it's a proxy war for
LGBT versus Antiquity is that really
that's really what it is I'm not saying
that's why you should cheer for Russia
or not but the rallying cry internally
for the Kremlin and the rally and cry
internally at NATO is that worse yeah
yeah Russia says we're super nut that
that that is the Mantra that both sides
are using regardless of what Ukraine
actually thinks it's sort of Ukraine is
just the Battle of course
unfortunately they're victims for all
this yeah yeah but the actual like the
leaders of the the leaders from Brussels
and the leaders from Moscow both use
social positioning as a way to Rally the
funding and the troops and the Personnel
in both their respective side that's so
true I mean this was one of the
arguments about the rest of the kind of
American Imperial project was I say okay
the Great American Empire
I mean truly I thought okay if we're
going to
spread our values around the world and
it's truth justice in the American way
okay great but if the thing we're
spreading around the world is the
rainbow flag and kandahars
then what are we doing why would we do
that this is the argument to end the war
in Ukraine is it's a proxy war for the
woke idea virus yeah and it supports the
whole state department their why is not
about the Constitution or consent to the
government or the Declaration or
fulfillment yeah fulfilling some sort of
madisonian mandate of like yeah you know
people-centered government the why of
the state department is that we can push
back that evil monster Putin Because he
believes one man one woman but is there
a fear this is the best argument I've
heard for us in Ukraine is there a fear
that if we allow if we wind down the war
let's say we allow Russia to take more
of Ukraine that that will embolden say
she in Taiwan they're already they're
creating their own currency in St
Petersburg in the next couple weeks yeah
but I mean what we should have done is
said Russia no you can have eastern
Ukraine hold elections and let's create
an actual force and strengthen the
dollar and then crush the CCP the
opposite is happening yeah you know have
India China and Russia going to St
Petersburg in the coming weeks they're
going to create a currency move to
destabilize the dollar so we're going to
possibly lose the dollar as the world
Reserve currency status because why
to support zelenski like the failed TV
actor made prime minister by the way
when the U.S loses if the Lewis U.S were
to lose Global Reserve currency status
you know all of a sudden our 100 110
debt to GDP ratio becomes a little bit
more of a problem than it is right now
all of a sudden for inflation you'll 30
inflation because all those dollars then
have to get released immediately as
their reserves right so Japan Korea the
Philippines Indonesia like okay here's a
wire transfer here's 300 billion dollars
coming home and then they'll have 30
inflation but don't worry hey supportive
zelenski's worth it
so you would rather play the game with
Putin yeah yeah
am I okay
climate change is obviously caused by
the Sun and has nothing to do with human
activity
there's no Nuance in any of these
questions
[Music]
yeah if I had to like tilt more side
than not that's how it answered for you
the AKA yes and for you as well did I
get there right yes ish only because
that's way too absolute it's way too and
it could be forget about even the humans
and the cars or whatever it could just
be weather patterns of course it could
just be all these natural kind of
geological things that have happened
yeah I don't think the sun is the only
contribution to global temperatures as
it is yeah but it doesn't need to be
that you know because it's not
necessarily carbon right carbon is life
you do not have life without carbon yeah
everything and everything that matters
is built on cars I also just love this
this lib idea well one obviously we all
know they've changed the climate story a
thousand times and it was It was kind of
cool and it was going to warm and it was
this and it was that but I love the idea
that until about 1968
the climate was just totally static
that's correct and the global mean
temperature whatever that means it was
just always exactly the same and then
that 1968 it all started to change and
that's why we've got to give up our
money and our rights and our cars but
then why do you think that is
well I think it has a little bit more to
do with a political campaign to upend
our order in our society than it does
with the sun monster it's also because
they don't like humans yeah of course
that's why they have to call
anthropogenic we're the problem yeah and
they believe nature untouched is the
ideal right right and nature is not holy
it is not orderly right nature untouched
is not moral and it's not personal God
is all those things right and and yeah
that's that's an important point because
they'll say oh we have overpopulation we
really don't for what yeah first of all
we don't but second of all
what is the nature for like if we're the
problem
we serve the Rocks is that it we serve
the deer well this is what river
civilizations used to believe though and
the Bible crushed this belief right they
believe that you worship the river you
worship the sun you worship the dirt and
the Bible makes the claim that go you
know this is for you you take dominion
over the Earth there's a hierarchy right
right nature man God when you when West
is built on that idea yeah when you
worship created things there is a word
for that it's uh not spoken very highly
of in the Bible that would be called
idolatry yes and that is exactly why
it's the first commandment well it's
actually the first statement you shall
know what regards before me yeah all
right you're up
I'll drink anyway I'll drink to that
drink to life
looking at the data women are actually
more shallow than men
foreign
well the statement is simply women are
more shallow than men
so yes women are more shallow than men
or no
nothing much tough because of double
night it's like a double negative right
the way I was racing it was no
okay I know it's very this is not or
more shallowed
so looking at women are actually more
shallow than men so I'd say no
to that statement meaning no women are
not
okay I think that
yeah I think that's who's more
superficial basically well it doesn't
necess it could be that they're both
equally shallow
it doesn't mean that one is more so than
the other did I get that right I don't
know
here's my argument here's because I was
trying to think about this so who's
deeper is that the question who who goes
deeper so you could make an argument and
say well it depends on what topic though
yes that's the issue and also I just
think of I think of the pieta you know
in in the Michelangelo pieta and I think
the depth of Mary's grief holding her
crucified son who is God and the son of
God
it probably doesn't get a lot deeper
than that
right so but but now men are deep in
other ways right men can be deeper in
some ways than women are men are always
deeper on the macro and women are always
deeper on the micro and this is prager's
whole thing right which is I mean I I
know you host radio if you if you're
talking about the stock market or
economics yeah Sports every single call
will be for men if you're talking about
relationships or divorce or gossip every
call will be from women right so when
that that picture of the paella is
exactly right the personal now what's
the equally as popular piece of art that
you'll see is Moses of the Ten
Commandments looking up to the heavens
Visionary abstract Big Ideas that's why
when men come home from work how is work
fine yeah right it's because it's too
detailed it's too micro it's too
immediate it's just not it's not
something that will dwell over yeah I
mean so women will replay conversations
in their head when men will think about
how you know we can retake Byzantine he
wears antium right that's a big
difference how can I go conquer the SARS
lessons yeah and then while they're
gonna be like are you sure my neighbor
likes me
are you sure and that's actually they're
both equally important though right yeah
and so because the argument against this
is the argument that got Larry Summers
fired which is he got fired because he
said that one of the reasons why there
aren't a lot of female mathematicians at
the you know the very highest levels of
Academia is because the bell curve of
intelligence for men is just wider and
so that means that the very very
smartest people on Earth are going to be
men and also the very very dumbest
people on Earth are going to be men and
this created a political uproar and he
was run out of Harvard even though Larry
Summers is actually pretty liberal
correct now the reason I don't think
that would be a good refutation of this
question is
depth is about a lot more than IQ I know
people have a relatively very high IQ
they're very shallow people correct
right and so I don't I'm not sure
there's a huge connection there yeah
again it depends on the topic micro
women are far deeper yeah macro I think
men are much deeper yeah okay that's
good
my wife has completely stopped shopping
at Target
for sure right
did you uh we had a conversation about
this on air no no no no not you and I
I'm my wife and I okay we she asked me
the other night she goes I make do what
we can't go to Target now I said we can
yeah I guess we can married like Whoopi
Goldberg wait wait that sounds you never
you never heard you know some people say
that that's not what my wife actually
sounds like to me that's a perfect
representation Mac
and so she goes she's like I like I've
never heard it described as a Whoopi
Goldberg boy it sounds like Whoopi
Goldberg from uh
some one of those movies that's that's
yeah from the Ted dance and comedy
special who knows I
I said to her we have to stop shopping
at Target because even though it has the
best variety and sometimes price on
Spindrift which I live on these are
sacrifices we have to make and people
have been called on to make bigger
sacrifices and they're they're just a
validly doubling down on transiting the
kids we can't shop there
right I mean we we didn't shop there
before it's they're dead to us Nick
right yeah but we have a whole list this
is why I like McCarthyism right is that
you have to have a list of the things
200. well it's like it's like North Face
Ford you know one after the other I was
never a an upper middle class Suburban
white girl so I never had the privilege
of wearing North Face but they're dead
to me I won't wear them anymore the Ford
truck that's I'm getting more of a sedan
guy but this is what's perplexing to me
I mean they do they really think oh yeah
the Raptor the Raptor well I mean out of
all the communities that are gonna buy
Raptors are they like you know what
you're right yeah Western San Francisco
they're obviously going to start buying
Raptors that's where they are that's
where Greenwich Village that's where you
see the highest proportion of raptors in
the country yeah not quite
we all owe Tom Cruise
I thank you and an apology he made top
gun Maverick and was totally right about
treating mental health issues with
prescription drugs
so you could rephrase the question and
say
Matt Lauer is glib
he's glib
[Music]
duh
Tom Cruise is Right Tom Cruise right
benzos are destroying so many young
people's lives Xanax ssris serotonin
disruptors yep yep we are over
medicating our society massively I do
think he's probably wrong about the
aliens coming and with the theatons and
the
but you're keeping an open mind no I
mean I'm a Christian I'm just saying
like I I don't think we have to always
overcompensate when somebody's right you
know I agree I think that he gets so
much unfair ridicule he totally does you
know he's kind of become a caricature
yeah yeah and if you look at the Matt
Lauer interview
he was so forceful about yeah now what
we clinically know which is now the
research is showing it the vast majority
of depression type diagnoses are not
actually anything that could be proven
Through Chemistry right it's about brain
health it's about whether or not you're
feeding yourself correctly vitamin D
levels right exercise what are you
consuming are you actually do you have
healthy dopamine habits are you dripping
dopamine or are you dumping dopamine
yeah Tom Cruise has talked about all
that he called it out in like 2005 I
think it was and also he's a marvelous
film actor he's truly the last he's just
great and pro-american the other thing
is because people always make fun of the
Scientology stuff but
think about all the other stuff that
Hollywood and just Libs in general
believe the crystals and the Reiki and
The Vibes and the energy or like you
have Sam Smith dancing to Satanist stuff
yeah like lay off him and right yeah I
mean obviously it's not my cup of coffee
but I just think the whole thing is so I
totally you know and I think honestly
they go after him so hard because he
criticizes Pfizer AstraZeneca moderna
and Johnson and Johnson yes yeah I
really do yeah yeah and when he when
he's sat there with total seriousness
and just said Matt you aren't glib that
was a precise word to describe the libs
the libs are very good okay
the catastrophic drop in male
testosterone levels over the past 50
years is the result of a plot to
feminize and turn the men into Libs in
order to make the population more easily
controlled by the globalists and
currently the only way to fight it is to
go to the freaking gym do a cold Plunge
at 35 to 45 degrees and stop touching
receipts wow based that's a really deep
cut to say that uh hold on due to
YouTube rules make your guess but do not
verbally confirm if the other person
guessed correctly give only an ambiguous
non-verbal confirmation
did you get all that
yeah so it basically says go to
rumble.com You're the answer download
the rumble app so you've got okay we'll
make the gas somehow but then we don't
confirm or deny how the person did
sure okay going to the gym I don't know
about the gym you know but okay wait out
of all the things we talked about that's
what's going to highlight it's really
that's holding no that's gonna violate
Michael's rules um okay so the plot the
catastrophic drop the only way you get a
step okay
I don't know if you got it right yeah
who knows
okay uh you're up
it's possible that if you interact with
an AI you're actually interacting with a
real demon
yeah for sure right have you ever agreed
with a guest as much as this no this is
actually truly other than
tall people are better at politics we
got to settle that one we have to set
that's going to be the next special
what it really means I know it has a
moral demand Napoleon was great as
politics not the best moral no he was
not yes exactly we'll have to we'll have
us entirely separate yes or no for that
otherwise I think we've agreed
on all virtually every issue one was
well the other one that we woman thing
no the yeah it was either the death
penalty or it was something else the
teachers but we also there was some
Nuance there was nuances okay all right
let's see if we can split it up for the
last one all right
we had a disagree more this is weird
enough time has passed
we can all finally admit that Princess
Diana was probably taken out before she
could totally destroy the entire British
Monarchy
that she was taken out she was saying it
was like MI6 or something like that
okay the only reason I'm gonna have to
disagree here the only reason why you're
a defender of the Intel agencies no no
you're telling us the whole story I have
to go back further the reason that that
prompt I have to answer no is because
the British Monarchy was destroyed after
the no I'm saying after James II was
unjustly routed out of England William
and Mary was their motive Princess
Diana's death
that's the real Essence that's what I
answered based on
was it just really an innocent car chase
was there a little more to the story
um
okay I'll tell you what I'm gonna put my
glass here just for a second just very
near to me
one time
I was in a situation where I had a
security agent near me and there was a
person who seemed a little bit out of
place it was occasionally taking glances
at me
and uh
I talked with a security agent later and
I said what do you think it could have
you know it could have just been a
coincidence and this was a period of
particularly heightened security
and he turned to me and he said you know
Mr Knowles
that's a security professional
I don't like coincidences
they happen but
as a security professional one would not
like them
you answered correctly there's
definitely more to that story
motive's unknown that's why I didn't
like the second part yeah okay motive
Center okay
is this the last one all right here we
go
you will find out more about somebody by
looking at their Discovery page on
Instagram than you would from going out
on a lunch date
foreign
[Music]
my friend really we got it wrong too I
did okay so and I'll you go first
My Discovery page on Instagram I'll I'll
tell on myself what is the really mean
Discovery page so you click on Instagram
there's the uh the magnifying glass and
it just shows you rant I think that's
the one it just shows you kind of just
random people's accounts and stuff and
mine is divided into there are only
three things that show up in in this Oh
I thought they meant like the profile
page no not the profile no no it's the
discovery like what the algorithm thinks
you are liking if you're if you're going
out on a random lunch date why would
somebody have a discovery page no
meaning like if let's say I want to know
about Charlie Kirk and I could and I
don't know oh so you got access to my
Discovery page exactly I understand okay
no then that's a different answer so
then you say no you think the lunch date
will tell you more than the discovery
page which one's which the no is
lunch date we'll tell you more the yes
is Discovery page we'll tell you more oh
launch date would totally tell you but
the discovery page is I mean the
algorithm is very good in that I get
three things on my algorithm I get
I like watches I like wrist watches here
I'm wearing a very fine Timex wrist
watch I don't they don't need to be
expensive but I like clocks and horology
I don't know why I've always have I just
like it okay it's a hobby
so it's an interest it's not even a
hobby I like
memes I like kind of funny memes and I
like music so you know guitar or piano
these things
it's the only three things that pop up
on my Discovery page and it's getting
smart in that it'll often be musical
jokes like it'll be guitar or piano
memes of and or it'll be kind of these
so it's good I mean the algorithm is
good but I like to think I like to think
that there's a little bit more to my
personality
than keeping time playing music and
laughing I liked it maybe I'm wrong
maybe Instagram knows me because if you
could go into somebody else's Discovery
yes yeah would you you think I watched
Instagram in years so oh you blessed man
you blessed me so so it is totally
managed by whole Team USA I don't have
access to any Mike social media accounts
that's so smart not even Twitter you
don't really wow
it's your mind Ben is like that yeah
yeah whole team managers at all so if I
want to tweet something I just say tweet
them so I don't use it I use Instagram
pretty infrequently I don't have Tick
Tock I don't really use Facebook unless
I'm searching for somebody to get in
contact
the one for me is Twitter I can't it's
about my Twitter I that was tough I
can't give it up I love it after what
happened in the 2020 election I gave it
up I said I can't I can't deal with it
yeah
that's very good and the other thing is
it depends on who's on the lunch date
you can find out a lot about a person on
a lunch day if you're a bad
conversationalist if you're not
interested in the other person but it's
a lunch date not a dinner date it's
different that is different because you
only you have three martinis at lunch at
dinner who knows
I didn't even I'm actually Charlie your
teetotaling is worn off on me oh is that
right look at that that's a very that
not a lot for you that's not I should
have had at least three of these
martinis
then I would be speaking in cursive
you'd be speaking in tongues like a true
Pentecost yes um at least in my mind I
would be yes uh Charlie I think we both
won oh okay we'll have to have you back
we'll we'll discuss the the height Quest
so it's like world war one where you
it's just it's a complete stomach until
World War II
who's on what side who's on what's a
question also for the next time until
then I'm Michael Knowles this is Charlie
Kerr happy playing
[Music]